tout le monde a son masque la visite des
grottes que commencer allez je vous
laisse descendre jusqu'en bas si ya à
peu près une merde on pourrait la tour
est cette même mouvement à la dépose et
d'essai d'imama et quand il s'est retiré
il ya 65 millions d'années
ces sédiments marins ils ont séché ils
ont durci en langue farmine roche
dominante en tourelle le duo les grottes
de savonnières se sont formés sous les
coups de pioche des bâtisseurs du moyen
âge pour extraire la pierre tendre et
calcaires du tuffeau encore utilisé
aujourd'hui à quelques mètres sous terre
la température est de 14 degrés 33
l'extérieur la visite est intéressante
et rafraîchissante
ça m'intéresse assez et avec les
chaleurs qu'on a à l'extérieur on s'est
dit que pour les enfants c'était pas mal
aussi de se retrouver un peu au frais et
c'est sur notre passage en vélo c'est
surtout à trouver des petites
attractions pour pas passer la journée
sur un autre sur le vélo ici les eaux
d'infiltration contient de la silice
elle donne un léger sentiment aux parois
de la grotte pétrifié par le calcaire
une alchimie qui a permis de créer des
objets artistiques insolite soit mettre
un objet donc qui permet dans un verre
porcelaine terre cuite et faïences donc
sous les sources
on va le laisser pendant une durée qui
peut être six mois un an à 1 à 3 ans
voire même deux à trois ans on va
attendre qu'il se recouvrent de calcaire
et à force donc l'objet au lieu qu'ils
soient colorés comme on peut le voir les
arrières mois eh bien il sera tout blanc
et ouvriers surprenant surprenant de
voir ce qu'on peut faire avec
avec du calcaire en fin de contrat donc
ouais c'est une bonne à une bonne
expérience quand même faire pas mal de
choses même si nous dans nos maisons ils
nous embêtent mais là c'est vrai qu'à
l'intérieur des grottes c'est quand même
impressionnant ce que le calcaire peut
faire le site de savonnières est ouvert
depuis un siècle et il attire toujours
les visiteurs même pendant la crise
sanitaire
les touristes sont là c'est une bonne
saison on n'oublie pas quand même des
trois mois de fermeture le duo
confinement mais ça restait en tous cas
sur juillet-août une très bonne saison
et cette affluence de visiteurs dans les
lieux souterrains
on le doit aussi un peu au réchauffement
climatique un mal pour un bien